slightly
um we're just hearing now jonathan what
about this that it will be in england's
group group b england usa iran and
either wales ukraine or scotland
so just
the
kind of draw that will fire the
imaginations of so many fans across the
british isles
wales thinking about getting to the
world cup for the first time since 1958
and scotland of course who always bring
such a colorful
injection of tartan humor and
enjoyment and joy to any football
tournament they would be if they can
make it through the playoffs in that
group b against england a really
tantalizing prospect and just extra
impetus i think now for scotland and
wales through the course of the playoffs
that they will play in june the dates
are still a bit to be decided because of
the conflict in ukraine so
the the scenario that they face those
three sides wales scotland ukraine is
that whales have already got through
their semi-final so they will be in
the the playoff match and scotland and
ukraine still have to face each other
and the winners of that game will go
through to face wales so it will be
scotland wales or ukraine in that group
b
against england the usa and iran so the
british nations still involved in this
tournament have been drawn together in
qatar in the last few seconds and what a
prospect that is what a prospect indeed
what are the chances okay tom many
thanks indeed and thanks for staying
with us until uh we got the the complete
lineup thanks very much so the breaking
news this hour england will face the usa
iran and then either wales scotland or
ukraine